Queridos amigos de VisualPolitik, no es ningún secreto, la gran locomotora de los Estados
Unidos está funcionando a toda velocidad.
Tras 10 años de crecimiento ininterrumpido
la economía norteamericana vive un momento
fabuloso:
la tasa de desempleo se encuentra por debajo
del 4% - lo que supone el menor nivel desde
el año 2000; cada mes que pasa se crean más
de 100.000 nuevos empleos, los salarios crecen
y tan solo en los últimos 3 años, se han
creado casi 8 millones de puestos de trabajo.
Además, la producción industrial, el SP
500 y las exportaciones se encuentran en máximos
históricos. La locomotora vuela.
Sin embargo, amigos, esperad un momento, porque
la economía de los Estados Unidos también
tiene otra cara… De la cual ya os hemos
hablado aquí en VisualPolitik [os dejo el
enlace al final de este vídeo y también
en la descripción]
Queridos amigos, la economía norteamericana
- especialmente el gobierno - es adicta al
crédito y a la deudas.
Tal cual como lo escucháis.
Fijaos, el pasado 30 de septiembre de 2018
marcó el cierre del año presupuestario del
gobierno federal.
Pues bien, os hago una pregunta: ¿sabríais
decirme cuánto se incrementó la deuda federal
tan solo durante este ejercicio?
Pues ni más ni menos que en 1,3 billones
de dólares, billones en castellano, trillones
en inglés. 1,3 billones de dólares. Una
cantidad superior al todo el PIB de la economía
mexicana.
Y, ojo, estamos hablando tan solo del gobierno
federal.
La economía crece, pero el déficit público
está fuera de control. Durante el último
ejercicio, con Donald Trump en la Casa Blanca,
por cierto, el gasto del gobierno creció
un 7%
Y las cosas parece que van a ponerse bastante
pero que bastante peor…
La oficina de presupuestos del congreso estima
que de seguir por este camino en menos de
10 años tan solo el pago de intereses le
costará al gobierno federal más de 900.000
millones de dólares cada año.
Sin embargo, queridos amigos de VisualPoltiik,
el gobierno federal no es en absoluto el único
adicto a la deuda. Atentos.
(LOS ESTADOS: LA DEUDA OCULTA)
La economía crece y los ingresos crecen.
En 2017, 39 de las 50 estados que componen
los Estados Unidos han tenido superávits.
Es decir, aparentemente han ingresado más
de lo que han gastado.
Tras años de ajustes, ahora la pregunta que
se hacen muchos gobernadores es… ¿Cual
es la mejor forma de gastar todo este dinero?
Y, ojo, que desde el año 2010 la recaudación
de los estados se ha incrementado un 40%,
así que... no penséis que estamos hablando
de unos pocos centavos, para nada.
Por fin, los estados cuentan con recursos
para invertir en infraestructuras, en educación,
en servicios sociales.
Suena bien, ¿Verdad?
Lastima que la realidad sea un poquito diferente…
bueno un poquito… completamente diferente.
(Veréis, en principio, todos los estados
a excepción de Vermont tienen el requisito
de tener un presupuesto equilibrado.
Sin embargo a pesar de ello y de todos los
aparentes superávits anunciados, lo cierto
es que los estados no dejan de acumular deudas,
obligaciones y pasivos de todo tipo.
De hecho, queridos amigos de Visualpolitik,
a día de hoy los estados arrastran, según
las estimaciones del Think Tank Truth in Accounting,
una pesada carga de más de 1,5 billones en
deuda no financiada.)
El resultado, amigos, es que la inmensa mayoría,
ni más ni menos que 40 de los 50 estados,
no tienen recursos para enfrentarse a todos
los compromisos que han adquirido.
Pero… un momento, ¿Cómo demonios pueden
los estados acumular deuda y al mismo tiempo
tener equilibrados sus presupuestos?
Pues… básicamente haciendo trampas contables
de todo tipo. Al fin y al cabo, los políticos
y los funcionarios electos son los primeros
interesados en enmascarar las cifras y gastarse
hasta el último centavo… Diantres, no os
enteráis, hay que ganar unas elecciones.
Son muchas las trampas que se utilizan…
desde inflar supuestos de ingresos hasta retrasar
el pago de facturas, pero… la trampa más
importante de todas es la que tiene que ver
con las pensiones y los beneficios para los
empleados públicos que se jubilan.
Veréis, me explico.
Con el objetivo de ganar votos y llevarse
bien con los sindicatos es habitual que los
gobiernos estatales prometan a los empleados
públicos unas pensiones muy buenas además
de un montón de beneficios adicionales cuando
se retiren.
(Pues bien, tal y cómo funciona el sistema
de pensiones en los Estados Unidos, se supone
que cada mes los gobiernos estatales deben
aportar a un fondo de pensiones las cotizaciones,
las cantidades comprometidas para que el día
mañana todos estos trabajadores públicos
puedan cobrar las pensiones que les han prometido.)
Sin embargo, amigos, os voy a pedir que nos
pongamos un momento en el lugar de los políticos
que están a cargo de los gobierno estatales.
[¿Y si en vez de ingresar todo ese dinero
en un fondo de pensiones lo dedicamos a todo
tipo de programas de gasto público? De esta
forma podremos financiar muchos proyectos
que nos harán a su vez ganar más votos.
Vale, puede que alguno de vosotros esté pensando…
¿Y qué ocurrirá cuando todos esos empleados
empiecen a jubilarse y a reclamar sus pensiones
y sus beneficios? ¿Cómo se va a pagar?
Y qué mas da. Eres político…ese problema
le tocará a otro… Tu preocúpate de ganar
las elecciones.]
Pues amigos, a tenor de los datos parece que
esta es la reflexión que se han hecho muchos
de los políticos estatales.
(“State and local governments made big commitments,
particularly on pensions and retiree health
care, but didn’t adequately fund those liabilities,”
Mr. Bronin, a Democrat and Mayor of Hartford)
En total, tan solo en lo concerniente a pensiones
no financiadas, las deudas de los estados
superan ya los 800.000 millones de dólares.
La gran duda es saber cómo diantres van a
poder hacer frente a toda esta enorme cantidad
de dinero.
Claro que, un momento, no penséis que todos
los estados están en la misma situación.
Para nada. Atentos.
(LOS MEJORES Y LOS PEORES)
Amigos, si lo pensamos un momento es fácil
de comprender: los políticos tienen un incentivo
gigantesco a gastarse hasta el último centavo,
al fin y al cabo… todo su futuro depende
de las siguientes elecciones.
Por eso es tan importante, absolutamente imprescindible
no solo existan contrapesos, sino también
que la sociedad civil esté atenta y sea muy
exigente.
Pero, volvamos al caso de los estados estadounidenses.
(Tal y como hemos visto, además de los datos
oficiales, arrastran una colosal deuda no
financiada de 1,5 billones de dólares.
Ahora bien, no todos los estados se encuentran
en la misma situación. De los 50 estados
que tiene Estados Unidos, ni más ni menos
que 40 no tienen a día de hoy activos suficientes
como para hacer frente a todas sus obligaciones.
Por supuesto algunos estados están mejor
que otros.
Y, en cualquier caso son 10 los estados cuyos
políticos han sido lo suficientemente responsables
como para garantizar el futuro del estado
y mantener unas cuentas ordenadas.)
Pues bien, estos son los 10 estados que han
hecho sus deberes: [Sí, no hay duda, se han
ganado cuando menos el derecho a tener una
mención propia, ¿No os parece? Alaska, Dakota
del Norte, Wyoming, Utah, Dakota del Sur,
Idaho, Tennessee, Nebraska, Oregon y Iowa.
[Cómo veis, casi todos, a excepción de Oregon
y Iowa son estados fuertemente republicanos.
Los democratacas deberían empezar a fijarse
en estas cosas.]
El caso es que el resto, todos los demás
estados, tienen a día de hoy un balance con
números rojos.
Claro que, de todas formas, para que nos hagamos
una idea de lo que estamos hablando, echemos
un vistazo al siguiente gráfico que recoge
los 5 mejores estados y los 5 peores.
(CHART: en telegram)
Los datos están expresados en dólares por
contribuyente. Y sí, lo habéis visto bien.
(Mientras estados como Dakota del Norte, Wyoming
o Iowa han sido responsables y han acumulado
suficientes ahorros como para hacer frente
a todas sus obligaciones - e incluso contar
con excedentes que podrán ser invertidos
en beneficio de cada estado -, Illinois, Connecticut
y New Jersey arrastran un terrorífico agujero
de más de 50.000 dólares por contribuyente.)
Pero claro, llegados a este punto la pregunta
es ¿Qué diantres van a hacer todos estos
estados para poder pagar sus obligaciones?
La respuesta no es sencilla… porque la situación
de algunas estados, como hemos visto es el
caso de Illionios, Connecticut y New Jersey
es tan mala que parece difícil encontrar
una solución.
(En el caso de New Jersey, el estado en peor
situación de todos, el agujero fiscal, en
números contantes y sonantes, asciende a
casi 200.000 millones de dólares. Es decir,
que el agujero de estado que tiene poco más
de 9 millones de habitantes es más grande
que la economía de Qatar y casi tan grande
como las economías de países como Nueva
Zelanda o Perú. ¡De locos!)
En cualquier caso, lo que sí podemos decir
que en última instancia tan sólo hay dos
caminos posibles: o subir impuestos o recortar
el gasto.
El problema es que subir impuestos… puede
no ser ni siquiera una opción en tanto en
cuanto puede dañar el potencial económico
del estado y ahuyentar a muchos contribuyentes,
especialmente a las grandes fortunas.
Eso es precisamente lo que ha ocurrido en
Connecticut donde durante los últimos años
un montón de grandes empresarios se han huido
del estado por culpa de sus altísimos impuestos
en comparación con otros territorios de los
Estados Unidos.
Y no solo en Connecticut. En 2016, el último
año del que tenemos datos, 600.000 personas
se movieron de los 25 estados con los impuestos
más altos a los 25 estados con impuestos
más bajos. Y tras la última reforma fiscal
de Donald Trump es previsible que este proceso
se acelere.
Pero, amigos, de todo esto hablaremos en un
próximo vídeo.
De momento, el caso es que como veis la adicción
por la deuda no es ni mucho menos un problema
exclusivo del gobierno federal.
La economía de Estados Unidos marcha viento
en popa, pero a día de hoy esta es la otra
cara de la moneda.
Lo cierto es que para que todo el crecimiento
que está teniendo el país sea sostenible
tanto el gobierno federal como los gobiernos
estatales tienen que empezar de una vez por
todas a tomarse muy en serio todo el tema
del déficit y la deuda pública.
No es normal que un país con semejante crecimiento
experimentó tantos desequilibrios en las
cuentas públicas… ¿No os parece? ¿qué
va ocurrir cuando vengan las cosas mal dadas?¿Dónde
está el limite al tanto endeudamiento?
Porque amigos, no lo olvidemos: tarde o temprano,
de una forma u otra la deuda pública siempre
se termina pagando.
Si este vídeo te ha resultado interesante
no olvides darle a like y suscribirte a VisualPolitik
si aun no lo has hecho. Un saludo y hasta
la próxima.